so liebe leute ich melde mich von dem
gesellschaftlichen ereignis hier in köln
in diesem jahr ich habe der absolute
höhepunkt so viele journalisten gibt es
hier selten auf einem fleck und jetzt
was auf 6 julia und ich dürfen auf roten
teppich aber also dass zum ersten mal
julia und ich wir sind genau richtig auf
der playboy party in köln ich hatte mich
der playboy club eröffnet und wir dürfen
jetzt mal auf den roten teppich
hammer
schön
hallo
unterschicht
der klaus hat sich
und können sie das unterstützen
die nase voll
lässt du sehr streng ist wenn du nicht
erleben benutzt den stein gefangen
nehmen ist nicht gerade der christoph
krachten und wir wollen damit ein foto
machen
ja das was von der playboy party hier in
köln
die geht noch ohne ende weiter und der
hauptzweck des cluster playmate stehen
und so graviert werden deswegen das
highlight war natürlich einmal 60 auf
dem roten teppich und vor allem
irgendwie und klaus dafür nächsten thema
party